on Monday Marvel Comics admitted what
those of us who actually read comic
books have known all along the emphasis
on left this messaging in comic books
it's pretty much killing the appeal
David Gabriel is the vice president of
sales at marble and he said the comic
book retailers were reporting a drop-off
in interest in the new diversity
oriented comics he said quote what we
heard was that people didn't want any
more diversity didn't want female
characters out there that's what we
heard whether we believe that or not I
don't know if that's really true but
that's what we saw in sales any
character that was diverse any character
that was new our female characters
anything that is not a core Marvel
character people were turning their nose
up okay it's not racism and sexism
driving people away from Marvel it's a
feeling of irritation that classic
characters are being redrawn and recast
in order to assuage the feelings of
social justice warriors Iron Man is Tony
Stark he is not RiRi Williams Captain
America is Steve Rogers he is not Sam
Wilson Thor is Thor not female for
spider-man is Peter Park it not Miles
Morales this is insane to the comments
with Miles Morales aren't good they're
actually really good if you read them
although the Iron Man series was really
root with riri will Williams actually
kind of suck it's to say that nobody
wants to see iconic superheroes recap is
completely different people to appease
quotas on race and sex superheroes are
brands you can't twist those browns
without hurting them when it comes to
new superheroes people are always
skeptical so this poses something of a
challenge how do you better reflect
diversity and comments without tanking
sales that's something you want to do
the answer you have to make new
characters awesome then worry about
whether their diverse later or use a
historic character to infuse new life so
Marvel did the ladder with Black Panther
they hire Donaghy's he codes to write
the comic which immediately became a big
bestseller for them this year the
comments by the way is actually
unreadable bad but at least Marvel tried
doing diversity the right way here in
the DC Universe Harley Quinn who was a
marginal character twenty years ago is
now a major bestseller because she's
interesting not because Batman had to
become that woman but the comic book
industry keeps attempting to slam its
constituents over the head with social
justice messaging and that's actually
killing the quality of comics see for
example Batman advocate for Trayvon
Martin or Captain America illegal
immigration defender both of which
happened last year turning iconic
characters into avatars of social
justice actually kill sales it's
throwback comics doing most of the heavy
lifting at this point Marvel and DC
should take note that it's not American
racism driving that choice it's
Americans discontent with the left
willingness to sacrifice quality and
legacy for leftist politics I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
alright so we can get to the big
breaking news that is happening right
now in just a second something that is
really bad for the Obama administration
and pretty good for Team Trump we'll get
to that in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our advertisers
over at texture so if you're somebody
who is addicted to information if you
are an information addict like I am if
you love magazines if you love reading
spend every waking hour reading texture
is for you it is an app that you
download and it allows you to subscribe
basically to up to 200 magazines with
one subscription fee so basically you
pay in it's like 992 yes nine
ninety-nine a month and you get over 200
free magazines but if you sign up right
now at texture com so I spend to get a
14-day free trial so you get to check it
out you get the back of issues and again
they're offering that 14-day free trial
I use it for Reader's Digest we use it
also for Sports Illustrated they have an
entire list of magazines New York or
time the Atlantic Canada fair if you
like long-form journalism it is perfect
for you you get them all in one app to
go to texture calm /femme its texture
calm / been and it means they're never
gonna be bored again basically you're
sitting there with your phone and you go
to your texture app you open it up you
see what's the latest and it is just
fantastic again 999 a month to get over
200 magazine and you can try for free
for 14 days see if you like to go to
texture calm / been to check it out it
is entirely digital and it is the
easiest way to feed your need for
information texture calm / spend 14 day
free trial again I love it my wife uses
it as well it's really terrific ok so
the big story of the morning was late
breaking it actually broke a little bit
over the weekend but now it's been
confirmed from Eli Lake at Bloomberg so
originally it was broken with Mike sirna
vich for some reason the White House is
now funneling stories to my sternum itch
which makes very little sense because he
has very little credibility but you I
like then confirmed it and so did Maggie
Haberman over at the new york times they
she did the legwork so you I lekha
Bloomberg has now reported that Barack
Obama's national security adviser Susan
Rice repeatedly requested information
from the Intel community on members of
the Trump transition team in campaign
unmasking them to an audience beyond the
Intel community in the process now
normally when you get a raw Intel feed
and you're a member of the political
branches they basically black out all of
the people who are American citizens
caught up in the in the Intel so let's
say
listening to the Russian embassy and
they are talking to Mike Flynn the Intel
one is provided to people like Susan
Rice will say Russian ambassador was
talking to US citizen one right it'll
just black it out because it's not
important if there's no crime being
committed for people to know who this is
because they're afraid of exactly the
sort of thing the whole point of masking
is to prevent the dissemination of
information about innocent Americans who
are not actually doing anything criminal
so what happened is that apparently
according to lake in February the
National Security Council senior
director for intelligence Elliot Cohen
wat Nick discovered writes his multiple
requests to unmask US persons in
intelligence reports that are related to
trump transition activities he brought
this to the attention of the White House
General Counsel's office who reviewed
more of Rice's requests and instructed
him to end his own research into the
unmasking policy the intelligence
reports were some rates of monitored
conversations primarily between foreign
officials discussing the Trump
transition but also in some cases direct
contact between members of the Trump
team and monitored foreign officials one
US official familiar with the reports
said they contain valuable political
information on the Trump transition such
as whom the Trump Kim was meeting the
views of Trump associates on foreign
policy matters and plans for the
incoming administration now just last
month Susan Rice's on TV and she denied
she knew anything about members of the
Trump transition team being caught up in
incidental intelligence gathering that
now appears to be a lie as you I like
also point out the revelation that
require that writes requested the
documents would also help explain why
house Intel chair Devin Nunez went to
the White House a couple of weeks ago
because you could only see the logs what
rice was doing not from Congress he
actually had to go to the White House to
do that because that's where she used to
work it would also explain why Adam
Schiff the Democrat on the House Intel
committee basically has now gone silent
over the weekend after seeing those
documents at the White House is a huge
story for the Trump White House now
doesn't mean that Trump was right to say
that he was wiretapped by the Obama
administration no there's some evidence
that he was wiretap by the Obama
administration there is however
tremendous evidence now and in his
building day by day that the Obama
administration was seeking to compile
all of the intelligence information in
which the Trump team was incidentally
swept up and then disseminated it
broadly which led to being leaked that
is a scandal that is the Obama
administration targeting from team
officials that is the Obama
ministration without any sort of
evidence of nefarious activity targeting
the trump team they're not doing it
specifically by by saying we're going to
plant a wire in Trump's office which is
the next step but it is them saying we
have a higher level of suspicion and
we're going to unmask Trump team members
in the process which is truly a big
story it's a really big story actually
and the media have been ignoring that
story in favor of focusing in on Team
Trump which is really silly because
again the only evidence we have no
evidence on Trump Russia we have no
evidence that Obama wiretapped from well
we do have evidence of again and being
very specific about this because I want
to be truthful and I want to be clear I
am like so many others in this field I
actually care about what is true and
what the facts are as opposed to what
backs a particular narrative so Trump's
narrative that Obama was wiretapping him
or surveilling him that is not true he
was not being wiretapped or surveilled
in targeted fashion he was being
targeted in targeted fashion by susan
rice according to this report the
National Security Advisor under Obama
who is always the fall person right
she's always the person they tried out
to do the dirty work because she's an
Obama loyalist she was in fact unmasking
all of the Trump team officials by going
to the Intel community and requesting
raw intelligence be provided to her and
then disseminating that apparently
broadly it was widely dispersed across
the government that meant lots of people
knew that Mike Flynn was talking the US
ambassador surrogates who's Russian
ambassador sort of get his plea act
which of course led to Flynn's
resignation eventually and all of this
on the basis of nothing because there's
still two questions that haven't been
answered one what exactly did anybody do
wrong I am seeing the Trump team
actually do anything wrong at this point
it looks like all the stuff that Flynn
did that was that was nasty and terrible
he was doing two years ago he wasn't
doing well he was a member of the Trump
team that's number one and the number
two if team from knew about this and
apparently the White House General
Counsel's office knew about it why
didn't they just declassify this
information and blow it out there why
instead try to get it to Nunez wine said
try to funnel it through house Intel
maybe the idea here is that they knew
that they had their trust compromise
with the American people and then if
they crowded this out everybody would
accuse them of bias so instead they
tried to funnel it out through the House
Intelligence Committee maybe that's
what's going on but that's a question
that has yet to be answer and then of
course the last question is a small one
but an annoying one which is why in the
world the trump administration
leaked information to places like
infowars and zero hedge and sirna vajira
hedges actually much better than
infowars and certain of it why are they
using them as the outlets as opposed to
you know they're going to leak then
leaked to two outlets that have a higher
level of public trust I mean forget
about what i think of those outlets
those are not outlets with a high level
of public for us if you're going to leak
leak to somebody like you i like who
actually has a level of public trust
well all of this is leading the
democrats to sheer panic because they do
not actually have anything here it's
kind of fascinating the left keeps
focusing in on Trump Russia and Adam
Schiff representative ship he basically
admitted we've got nothing I mean
there's there's no hard evidence linking
Trump to Russian collusion is whether or
not there was collusion among members of
the Trump campaign or surrounding the
Trump campaign Trump advisors can you
say definitively that there was
collusion there were people affiliated
with the Trump campaign we're working
with Russians to time the release of
damaging information about Hillary
Clinton that event that had been hacked
either from John Podesta or the DNC I
don't think we can say anything
definitively at this point we are still
at the very early stage of the
investigation the only thing I can say
is that it would be irresponsible for us
not to get to the bottom of this we
really need to do we really need to find
out exactly what the Russians did
because one of the most important
conclusions that the intelligence
community reached is that they are going
to do this again to the United States
they're doing it already in Europe so we
can say you know conclusively this is
something that needs to be thoroughly
investigated but but it's way premature
to be reaching conclusions and basically
there he said no we don't have any
evidence of this whatsoever so what
exactly are you going to do about it and
is that the left has nothing here they
have nothing here and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders who's been bashed around a lot
for not being a particularly great
surrogate she's exactly right when she
says the media are talking about
something of which there is very little
evidence at this point the media
constant wants to talk about something
that doesn't exist instead of something
that does we have been we've spent the
last couple of months doing major policy
initiatives and roll out in the forms of
executive order rolling back regulations
creating an environment where businesses
are confident
and hiring again we've heard from CEO
after CEO small business owner that
they're excited about this president
they're excited about the economy and
yet the media refuses to cover that but
they're more than happy to talk about a
story frankly that is just faking it so
many Democrats are panicking over all of
this and so their language is becoming
more and more extreme excuse me on all
of this so you have the newark Mayor
who's now coming out and he's trying to
say that Trump is like a slave catcher
right they're just getting more and more
extreme because they're they're
panicking which is weird they shouldn't
be panicking Trump's approval ratings
are like thirty five percent right now
but by the same token there's nothing
that they've got on from pitts hard
evidence actually it is the thing
they're not content to live with
krumping an unpopular president instead
they are trying to go for the kill shot
and they don't have the killer shots
they're becoming more desperate so here
are the Democrats struggling here's New
York's mayor saying that Trump is
basically like a fugitive slave catcher
well I think that them targeting
sanctuary cities is a way for them to
tell mayors and other folks you know
around the country one that they are
sticking to what what I think is a very
unconstitutional and unamerican policy
and trying to intimidate us into being
what I've called Fugitive Slave catches
the run around and do their bidding in
our cities and if we refuse to do that
then it makes it difficult for them to
continue their policy because they don't
have the resources to kind of run down
all the undocumented residents locally
the desperation is setting in that is
pathetic okay the fact is that illegal
immigrants are not slaves in the United
States who are attempting to escape
bondage which is against both God's law
and man's law okay the idea that people
who are coming into the country
illegally and we don't know who they are
that you shouldn't be helping out the
feds to figure out who they are
masteress absurd but is it is the
language that is escalating now the
Democrats think that because Trump won
their answer is to escalate their
language they don't understand that the
reason that Trump won i just spent some
time in pennsylvania and i just spent
some time in indiana and i just spent
i'm spending time now in florida the
reason that trump won is because there's
a whole group of people in america who
feel like they were forgotten by the
democrats because the Democrats were too
focused on inflammatory language
dividing American from American to worry
about their jobs to worry about their
lives that's the reason live from one
but the Democrats are
thinking and looking at Trump and
instead of seeing that Trump appeal to a
certain number of people who felt
forgotten by the Democrats instead they
think that Trump won because Trump was
loud and so they're just getting louder
so here's Nancy Pelosi getting even
louder and more obnoxious well it is
always been Paul Ryan's agenda if you
look at the Ryan budget of the last
couple of Congress's before now you will
see that the agenda Donald can sign on
to that I think when he decide on the
nominee of the party he bought into the
deconstruction of government at the
radical right-wing agenda I don't even
know if Donald Trump will go as far as
the Republicans in Congress people say
well how long would take the Republicans
in Congress to say enough Donald Trump I
said don't wait for that because their
agenda is very similar to his if you
look at their budget over the last few
years if you look at their opposition to
anything to do with the environment
climate change in the rest if you look
at their anti-woman agenda LGBT agenda
you name it they've been there ok so
again getting more and more extreme in
the rhetoric now what this may help them
do what this may help them do is win
back the house nancy pelosi did this in
the aftermath of bush winning in 2004
after 2004 she got more and more extreme
and right now Trump is cruisin for a
bruisin in the house he's probably going
to keep it Senate because there are too
many Democratic seats up for play but in
2018 the house races do not look good
for Republicans right now when the when
the President of the United States is
below forty percent the chances that
he's going to retain the house become
lower and lower but again the Democrats
are just going to get more extreme in
their language that's not going to help
defeat Trump it is going to help drive
his approval ratings down Tom Perez did
the same thing is the chair of the DNC
will play him in just a second but first
I want to say thank you to our
advertisers over at Zeile com so one of
my favorite services I've used it my
wife has used it my parents have used it
my parents-in-law have used it my sister
has used it zeal calm is all about
massage on demand so if you need a
massage because your back is screwed up
or because you're stressed out and you
really want to treat yourself feel calm
is the way to do it you go over to zeile
calm and use promo code been and if you
use that promo code then you get twenty
five dollars off your first massage
they're all licensed massage therapy
they check you to make sure that you're
not some sort of creeper and then they
come over to your house they bring the
table they bring the oil they've written
the soothing music the whole deal and
they come over and they give you a
private massage on demand at a time of
your choosing you don't even have to
leave your house so much better than
trying to schedule in advance at the spa
less expensive than a spot like 100
bucks and our listeners can get twenty
five dollars off their first massage by
using that promo code been a check out
its zeal zeee elcom make sure you hit
that promo code add promo code events
use that check out at Zeile com you get
twenty five dollars off your first in
home on demand miss actually to eight
thousand masseuses across the nation
again I personally use this so has my
wife so many members my family they've
all been ecstatic over the quality of
the massages my mother-in-law was really
particularly happy with me which worked
out great for me because hey
mother-in-law so you're definitely it's
a great present for somebody it's great
for yourself and it's really a lot less
expensive than trying to do it the sort
of traditional massage way plus much
more convenient they come to you as
opposed to you having me go sit in the
lobby similar and wait for your
appointment to come up okay so Tom Perez
is ahead of DN C and he like Nancy
Pelosi liked its newark mayor he thinks
that the weight democrats are going to
win is by mirroring Trump's rhetoric
rather than mirroring Trump's
positioning with regard to blue collar
workers so here's Tom Paris ranting
about the GOP January was of the night
an important day in this country but
January 21st
[Applause]
you know this for our values ended any
and then he starts cursing as well a lot
of people on the right in saying oh how
dare he cursed Donald Trump's the
president we don't get to say how dare
he curse anymore okay that cat is long
out of the back but it does demonstrate
the Democrats as always take exactly the
wrong lessons out of their loss instead
of figuring out that they need to appeal
to the same people that Trump one away
from the Obama acolyte they instead have
decided to double down on his sort of
rhetoric now as we continue here i wanna
talk about Donald Trump's credibility
what Donald Trump is doing right what
Donald Trump is doing wrong and now what
an opportunity he has and how he needs
to push it forward but for that you're
gonna have to go over today lee weyer
calm right now become a subscriber eight
dollars a month will get you that
subscription you get access to the rest
of the show you can watch it live you're
also going to be able to get access to
the shapiro store which I keep promising
is coming but it actually is right now
for an annual subscriber you get a free
signed copy of Michael moles
best-selling book reasons to vote
Democratic comprehensive died the most
thorough guide to voting Democrat there
is also makes a great gag gift that is
that is to get the annual subscribership
from but it is great to be a member at
daily wire because not only get my show
live you also get Clavin the show live
plus you can be part of the mailbag
which you are doing on thursday so go
over there and become member or listen
later at itunes and soundcloud for for
the rest of the show as you listen there
make sure that you leave a review
because we always appreciate it tonight
I'm speaking at university of florida by
the way so you should be able to watch
that we're live-streaming it over at
daily where comm check that out in the
meantime we are the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
you